hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast and
um just checking in specifically the
ladies I'm checking in on the ladies to
make sure that you feel okay that you
feel like you're in a safe space to
listen to this podcast not because I
care because I want to start trending on
Twitter Jesus Christ Jesus Christ with
the award shows in the [ __ ] the same
speech given every award show always
called brave as if somebody's gonna
heckle it you know nobody's gonna say
that they're all gonna sit there and be
like wow that thing that was already
said was just said again but this time
it was said even better I wouldn't go up
there and say the thing that was already
said I would you want to be brave you go
the other way listen I know there's a
lot of guys out there took their dicks
out at work but what about these
gold-digging [ __ ] am i right fellas
that now that would be brave that would
be brave okay yeah and I think to see
you [ __ ] walk out of that one saying
the thing that's been said that
everybody gets once again we'll be right
back with thee saying the thing that's
always said it everything now awards
show after these messages
you know people while we were away
something else was said that was already
said that needed to be said again in
case anybody didn't hear it the first
19,000 times it was said you know and
like I swear to God and this is all it
does is it just causes a copycat [ __ ]
behavior same thing with these mass
shootings you know which is why they
shouldn't report on them because then
everybody wants to do it right [ __ ]
some chick makes a porn and becomes
[ __ ] super famous and every brought
out there starts [ __ ] dropping their
panties I looked at out
right so now [ __ ] Pete is getting
into it they're trying to say you can't
say beat a dead horse and then they day
came up with all this dumb [ __ ] there's
no [ __ ] way that this this can't be
coming from Peter like they said when
it's raining out don't say it's raining
cats and dogs that promotes violence
towards it's just you know you know can
you say it's a frog strangler
um you can't listen to Christmas music
you know what I mean are they gonna go
through all of the catalog now that song
I really can't stay cuz baby it's cold
outside I really can't stay was saying
that that promoted some sort of rape
well then don't sit under the apple tree
what anyone that's controlling she can
fit under whatever apple tree she wants
to I think the meaning was that was hey
don't go and [ __ ] suck some other
dick while I'm off fighting war you know
fighting a war here defending the
country you know but you know you
couldn't say that back then right baby
it's cold out was it good wait I really
can't stay baby it's cold outside I
gotta go away baby it's cold outside
this evening has been then hoping that
you drop in so afraid this is such a
cute [ __ ] song there's a bunch of
[ __ ] songs out there that you can
just turn into some [ __ ] right
anyways needless to say that's my new
walk-on music when I do a stand-up show
[Laughter]
you know it's funny I don't even like
that song it's it's a [ __ ] corny
goddamn song I don't even [ __ ] like
it but I'm such a [ __ ]
you know actually to be honest with you
I think there needs to be some sort of
turning down the spicket on this [ __ ]
insanity because it's literally 8% of
the population is acting like they're
speaking for or evidently babysitting
the [ __ ] rest of us but like I think
I can listen to that song and not rape
anybody
I've done it for 50 years I'm gonna go
out on a limb and to think I'm gonna be
okay you know this goes like back to
when they thought
the Judas Priest and all of that [ __ ]
you know made you go out and [ __ ]
kill yourself and do all which we all
know is it's it really comes down to
just bad parenting here's the thing I
know most women don't give a [ __ ] about
you know if you put on that song you
don't have me I know okay I don't know
was it brave to do what I just did
that's what you do you go on an award
show you do a [ __ ] tap dance to I
really can't stay and then you come out
and you talk about gold-digging horse
you know and then you try to like you go
for the the anti that crowd I bet that
could still fill an arena right I'm
sorry I don't know what the [ __ ] I'm
talking about here [ __ ] PETA I love
animals too do you know how much of a
douche you have to be for somebody to be
behind your cause and also to be sitting
there going the age people are [ __ ]
[ __ ] I think I just described myself
as a person cuz my wife loves me but she
really seems to side with other people a
lot of the times you know anyways let's
let's let's let's plow ahead here into
the podcast into the podcast I want to
thank everybody on the set for having me
on I had a great time promoting season 3
of Ethel's from family as far as I can
tell from the tweets it seems to be
going really well people seems to be
really enjoying it but why wouldn't they
we already have a great cast we already
have a bunch of murderers in the writers
room and we added Vince Vaughn that's
right spoiler alert listen closely Vince
Vaughn you'll hear his voice or the
character that he's doing on season 3
and I'm really excited that people are
enjoying it and I just want to say right
now to all the brave people out there
that are fighting out there to try and
get Netflix I just want to you to know
that your voice is heard it's heard by
me and that there's a bunch of people
out there that love you when you try to
sign on and just you know try to stay
positive I flew back from New York
yesterday and a little knows one of the
rare times of the year where you land
over the water on a telly actually
usually you know usually the wind's
coming in off the water so you take off
and land into the wind but this is time
we actually came around landed it was
pretty [ __ ] cool except was too
cloudy for me to see the approach you
know I'm a [ __ ] nerd when it comes to
that stuff but anyways when I was on the
plane I actually watched a Premier
League soccer game I want I watched
Arsenal vs Man United and I gotta tell
you I really [ __ ] enjoyed the game
you know and I'm starting to understand
it I saw now I understand why one thing
was offside you know when they all line
up and they cover their junk and
somebody tries to [ __ ] Bend It Like
Beckham around him you know like that
stupid ass movie I never [ __ ] saw
they were saying that this they scored a
goal on that maybe they were off sign
it's basically any party a body that
could score a goal if it's behind that
line on the offense if you're an
offensive player so this guy went to go
make a move and as you know you lead
with your head when you start to run
unless I don't know you're doing that
dance underneath the stick there right
so I guess he was offside so I guess I
understand that it really takes away a
lot of the excitement he should be able
to take off a little bit well I get it
because they have to stand there and try
to block it and then if the offensive
players you know they don't give a [ __ ]
they want theirs it's gonna take off
okay I get it I got to tell you some bad
bad bad [ __ ] defense and that goddamn
game you time Arsenal scored then they
turn around they just [ __ ] gave up
another one that long [ __ ] pass I
don't know any of the terminology which
I just know that that that shouldn't
happen sorry lollygaggin going after the
ball and that little [ __ ] came running
up and kicked it in with his [ __ ] toe
hair that shouldn't happen but it was uh
it was a great game and um I don't know
I haven't been drinking it just made me
want to booze there's something about
watching a Premier League game at night
it's always [ __ ] raining yeah it's
always like misty it just looks like
yeah I want to [ __ ]
start the fire and drink like you know
seven or eight pints why wouldn't you
it's all about saying a pint you feel
like you're a [ __ ] world traveler and
you don't feel like you're a [ __ ]
alcoholic speaking of which I actually
watched this thing on YouTube called
what kind of drinker am i that I'll be
discussing with Joe DeRosa on uninformed
the next episode on my patreon page and
I went and I looked up those alkie
questions cuz this guy sounded like me
like you know I can stop when I want to
I don't wake up shaken and have to drink
[ __ ] booze I'm not an alcoholic what
kind of drinker am i okay are and I
answered the questions to it all right
are you an alcoholic
alright here we go here we go
drug addiction treatment are you high
functioning wait I got to see Oh quiz
alcohol problems screening quiz oh boy
oh boy if I'd okay question one okay do
you sometimes drink more than you plan
to drink oh I don't have a plan other
than I'm going out let's see if I drink
it all I have only one or two before
dinner okay I hope any joke I tell
tonight will be funnier than that line
no that's not me I will occasionally
skip or delay meals to have a couple
more drinks
well I've drank for a period where I
didn't realize I mean I drink until I'm
hungry you know then I get a slice at
the end of the night wait sometimes a
few with the boys slash girls turns into
an entire evening well I never just go
out for a few I go out with the specific
I go out to get hammered I've been on
benders that lasted for days no I
haven't done that I mean I
unless you call consecutive nights of
drinking but I mean I sober up what am i
doing then the next night I have another
one alright do you sometimes drink more
than you plan to drink if it'll
occasional skip sometimes I guess the
closest one was would be the third one
see sometimes a
you with the boys / girls turns into an
entire evening yeah that's fair
alright let's check that at the end of
this quiz someone's trying to make money
off me so you know I'm gonna flunk it
and I need their help alright have you
ever tried to quit drinking and were
unsuccessful I don't want to quit I
enjoy an occasional drink I've thought
about quitting but I've just gotten
around but I haven't got around to it
I've tried to control my drinking but it
hasn't worked for very long I've tried
to quit drinking many times I go on
sabbaticals I like I need to shut it
down and I've been able to do that but
then I just get bored
let's keep poured and I you know like
what am I never gonna have another drink
so I guess I've tried to control my
drinking and it hasn't worked for very
long well I've gone a year alright how
much time do you spend each week
drinking oh Jesus Christ I don't know I
only drink on special occasions I don't
know I only drink on weekend and I drink
at least three nights a week now we're
getting there
I drink almost daily as soon as I get
off work ding ding ding ding ding
alright do you have
and you ever get an urge to drink or a
craving for alcohol yes okay no I can
take it or leave it Jesus Christ
somebody works at a library alright
sometimes if I've gone a few days
without a drink I'll get a desire to
drink yes if I skip a day drinking I'll
have an urge to drink the next day no I
can't wait until happy hour every day
I'd say to the second one number five Oh
Billy booze hounds he's almost halfway
there right how many [ __ ] questions
are there eleven do you often get bored
taking multiple choice two questions all
right
do you often miss work or school or
obligations that no I don't ever
remember miss no I've never I've never
no no never
I'm a pro I wait till after the works
done has your drinking negatively
affected your social or family
relationships
no I rarely drink enough to become
intoxicated no sometimes I have an
embarrassed
myself while drinking yes I prefer to
hang out with people who drink as much
as I do yes to that I have lost friends
relationship no it's somewhere between B
and C in some times I have embarrassed
myself while drinking and I also prefer
to hang out with people who drink as
much as I do
so I guess I picked the worst of the two
that's only fair
have you given up hobbies or activities
you used to enjoy no alcohol doesn't
interfere with my life no it doesn't I
think of my functioning does your
drinking ever put you in a dangerous
situation when I drink it's only at home
that's not true I have had a couple of
drinks at lunch no return to work I have
drink
I have drinking I've driven after
drinking before but I was not really
drunk bad back in the day before I got
arrested I was 21 I regularly drive home
from the bar no I don't drive home so
where do I go with that one I have
driven after drinking before but I was
not really drunk well I've done that
yeah you wait till you're sober I'll
click on that one as drinking caused you
any persistent health problems
no all right there we go does alcohol
still give you the same feeling one
drink helps me relax yeah three beers
used to do it now it takes a six-pack I
changed to liquor because wine wasn't
giving me a buzz I changed the liquor
cuz for the outfit calories I thought it
was you know I mean I know they all have
high calories but I figured I've just
got a little shot glass if it's supposed
to twelve ounces alcohol still give you
the same feeling well I guess the closer
one you know one one drink helps me
relax but I have changed to liquor
because wine wouldn't give me a buck
well would but I have to drink too many
then I get like [ __ ] acid reflux with
that [ __ ] alright when you go out
without alcohol do you get withdrawal
symptoms no I don't feel any negative
all right so now what does that mean
you have a know you got a moderate
alcohol problem well I could have
[ __ ] told you that anyways yeah no
I've been I've been a good boy I haven't
drank since the end of [ __ ] November
I'm coming up on two weeks you know what
I'm doing it during the holidays and
everybody's like ain't doing that I got
to get in shape for this [ __ ]
European run that I'm doing European run
bill you don't say I've seen it on your
website boy oh boy a lot of them sold
out any chance they had his second shows
in some cities January 5th Munich 2nd
show
January 6th often buck they added a
second show
January 8th and Riga Riga modal they
added a second show Vienna they added a
second show
Liverpool my adopted [ __ ] Premier
League team I think I don't know I got a
I got a pick a team but I think it's
gonna be them and I'm doing it because I
like the Beatles
London they added a second show March
5th
Copenhagen Denmark April 30th and
Helsinki they added a second show I love
it alright old daddy's gonna be over
there [ __ ] working so yeah that's why
I cut it off I I got some sort of
[ __ ] he she was last night I was
sitting by the with my wife
I lit you know put the Christmas lights
on a tree and all of that [ __ ] we're
having a great time I love the holidays
so she goes you want some eggnog
a little in there you know she says and
I said nah I'll just take the eggnog but
I you know a little bit of uh what's
that [ __ ] you put on top of it the brown
stuff nutmeg a little nutmeg on top and
I'll be good excuse can't have just a
little bit I go no cuz then I want to
have a bunch more and then that could
turn into you know me drinking every
night for the next week or for the next
year just about you know I'm a habit guy
and if I'm not drink
I'm either on or [ __ ] off III be
honest with you I lost that ability to
kind of just like you know occasionally
have a beer I have to like be not doing
it or [ __ ] doing it now I cannot do
it I guess it's the free time and I got
too much [ __ ] free time if I had like
an you know what I need this I think the
biggest problem with my boozing is is I
don't I there's no rules that's all I
need because with like cigars I have
rules you know as far as so how many I'm
gonna have I just have to have rules
with alcohol so maybe like I was
thinking what if like two Saturdays a
month you know that would be perfect cuz
then I'd still go out and get to drink
cause I [ __ ] love booze but then I
won't be like negatively affecting
myself you know I also won't be bored
shitless and it also won't be a bloated
[ __ ] so maybe in I feel like in when I
do the European Tour maybe the second to
last night just so I'm not hungover for
the flight or whatever now cuz I know me
they don't be like oh my god this
flights [ __ ] long as [ __ ] when I just
have [ __ ] three doubles real quick
and just pass out wake up over [ __ ]
Greenland and be like yeah [ __ ] really
if we did it man whatever I'll figure it
out I'll figure it out um let's see here
maybe I'll go to an AEA meeting every
time I go to a [ __ ] a meeting like
Jesus Christ these [ __ ] people are
crazy I just sit in a bar and drink and
I get hammered and then I gig I [ __ ]
go home that's it you know there's no
cops
there's no [ __ ] family [ __ ] coming
down dad
these [ __ ] stories there's no blood
jail and [ __ ]
all right butcher box everybody butcher
box delivers healthy 100% grass-fed and
grass-finished beef free-range organic
chicken and heritage bread pork the
incredible quality of butcher box meat
starts with the commitment to raising
animals humanely and free of antibiotics
and hormones before they're murdered
cook with the piece cook with the peace
of mind knowing you're eating healthy
high quality meat each box comes with at
least 18 to 11 pounds of meats which is
enough for 24 individual sized meals
unless you're a gluttonous fat [ __ ] you
know you probably burned through it
faster than I do a bottle of booze you
can choose from five different box types
all beef beef and chicken beef and mix
box custom box let you choose your own
cuts incredibly convenient think of
butcher box as your neighborhood butcher
delivered right to your door on dry ice
for free shipping anywhere in the 48
states choose your delivery frequency
with the customizable subscription for
free bacon and $20 off your first box go
to butcher box com slash / and
Interborough
at checkout all right oh look who's here
booth do me on these biondi's wasn't
that [ __ ] brave door doo doo doo
biondi's biondi's don't go to a [ __ ]
rave and drop [ __ ] Molly and stand to
work next to a creep next thing you know
his balls are in deep make sure you look
out for yourselves this holiday season
especially if they play baby it's cold
outside I'm talking right me undies
everybody soft as a [ __ ] deers ass a
reindeers ass have you finished your
holiday shopping yet no worries you can
get everything you need for your loved
ones that be undies me undies uses the
coveted micro motile modal fabric which
is three times softer than cotton if you
never felt this fabric get ready to
experience pure bliss and underwear form
you can also get a style that is
perfectly suited for you or that special
someone men and
can choose from four different cuts all
of which are available from classic
colors too adventurous Prince but but
why'd stop at the undies me undies has
cozy lounge pants and onesies in that
same supersoft fabric perfect for
wearing my balls of [ __ ] cold for
wearing Christmas morning offer me
undies has had a great offer for my
listeners for any first-time purchasers
you're with your when you purchase any
me undies you get 15% off and free
shipping order by 1216 for free shipping
in time for Christmas crunch for time
you can't go wrong with the me undies
gift card this is a no-brainer get 15%
off a pair of the most comfortable
undies you will ever put on to get 50%
off your first pair free shipping and
100% satisfaction guaranteed go to the
undies dot-com / / that's me undies calm
/ / and lastly but not leastly HELOCs
everybody you ever wake up in the
morning with regrets of what you've done
yeah replaying the terrible decisions
you made the previous night over and
over and over yeah the kicking the
sweating the yelling yeah oh whatever
else you do to piss everyone off in the
room well guess what bud just deciding
to sleep on a shitty mattress is your
choice well where would you buy
something that you would enjoy well
you're in luck because helix sleep the
mattress I'm yelling at you about for
almost two years will change your life
just go to helix sleep calm slash bar
take there two minutes sleep quiz and
they'll match you to the perfect
mattress it's like tinder for a finding
a mattress all the fun with none of the
next morning regrets in misery and right
now you can get up to 125 dollars off
your mattress order at helix sleep calm
/ / they have a hundred one hundred
night trial free shipping and won't send
you creepy next day text that's helix
sleep calm / / for up to 125 dollars off
your first mattress order all right
by the way that George Bush book that
was telling you we're talked about him
flying and all that [ __ ] that was called
flyboy snot flags of our Father
it's [ __ ] hilarious I barely read I
know that's not a surprise and I can't
remember the name of the goddamn book
that I [ __ ] read that was the one
with the George Bush stories that were
but you know I I didn't feel too bad
that I picked the other book too because
they're both incredible books all right
what else do we got here
uh let's see award show speeches talked
about that Arsenal man use my is
Christmas tree no booze I told you I'm
thinking about switching to smoking a
pipe both my grandparents smoked a pipe
and they're dead now so I think it's a
good Nam kid I just been thinking about
doing that I like it I like the whole
[ __ ] ritual it just seems really cool
sit down pack in the thing lighten it
having to relight it pack it down that
little [ __ ] thing cleaning it out the
whole goddamn thing
somebody get when I was in of course one
of my favorite cities of all time
Milwaukee Wisconsin I was there and they
gave me a pipe you know and I just I had
lost the thing and I just recently
founded it I also like you know what I
like about cigar smoking and and also
smoking a pipe is it's really [ __ ]
obnoxious like cigar smoke is just
because it's just all encompassing and
nobody can get away with get away from
it all right so I got a pipe I have some
pipe cleaner and then do I have in here
do I have a little [ __ ] I still got
to buy the thing to pack it down oh my
god dude are you serious
I get it I gotta try this [ __ ] thing
out you know oh there's a little thing
for though that I watched this whole
thing like first of all I notice people
who smoke pipes have crazy facial hair
like I don't know if I'm gonna fit in
like when I show up than good as a
newbie look at him he doesn't look like
he you know
he's a conductor or something like that
now GZ you know what I want for
Christmas I I really have to [ __ ] fix
this [ __ ] goddamn headphones here why
do I do this to myself what it you know
it's got to be this adapter thing that's
what it is I just had to buy a nice one
I'm literally I'm handling this right
now I'm gonna not right now but the
podcast is over in a couple minutes and
then we have some Greatest Hits another
half hour so please by all means okay
this is a safe space to listen to a
podcast anyways I'm gonna order one of
those goddamn things then I also got a
bunch of nieces and nephews and they're
all getting bossed and [ __ ] sports
[ __ ] alright I don't want to hear it
okay that's it I care about sports
therefore you're gonna care too and
speaking of which let's see when
Liverpool's next game is Liverpool
Liverpool come on because you know what
I have the whole [ __ ] month off and
bye I just knew by that I just mean I'm
not gonna [ __ ] oh come on give me a
break here all right
they beat Fulham to nothing they beat
Everton won nothing the next game is
Saturday 4:30 a.m. Jesus Christ [ __ ] am
I gonna watch that they got Man United
coming up that's got to be a big one
Sunday the 16th oh [ __ ] all right well
let's see what what's their [ __ ]
that's it they play once every 10 days I
kid I can't be right that can't be right
Liverpool three-to-one stat timeline see
everything's different in another
[ __ ] [ __ ] timeline what the [ __ ] is
that how do I get scheduled all right
let me hit pause here sorry hold on
alright yeah these games are nice and
spread out Jesus Christ this is [ __ ]
easy to follow alright so what do we got
they got one on Saturday then they got
Saturday the 8th then they got Sunday
the 16th then they got the 21st and the
26th then the 29th
I'll buy if I watch all of those games
I'll be on board I'll be on board all
right that'd be great I'm doing
Liverpool on on one of these tours
coming up you know I'm also doing
Manchester City so Jesus Christ I'll get
a bunch of [ __ ] they don't give a [ __ ]
right I'm so stupid yeah then I could
give a [ __ ] just be happy I'm watching
they won't give a [ __ ] the perfect
scenario would be if I become a
Liverpool fan and then they lose to Man
City right so then like Liverpool people
will be happy that I'm rooting for their
[ __ ] team and then Nancy won't give a
[ __ ] cuz my team didn't win bill I don't
think they're gonna give a [ __ ] either
way hey alright uh
anyways I'm so psyched to be home I'm so
[ __ ] psyched to be home I have the
best [ __ ] life in the world getting
married was the smartest thing I ever
did kid considering all the pitch and I
do about it it's [ __ ] great I'm gonna
go inside go have a nice [ __ ] get out
of the garage here going to get a nice
[ __ ] warm meal here sit around the
goddamn Christmas tree right have a good
time and in the meantime we're gonna be
listening to a little bit of [ __ ]
music here and then a half hour of
greatest hits for my Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcast from earlier this year or years
ago I have no idea by the way thank you
to everybody that bought tickets to
Patrice O'Neal comedy benefit on
February 19th 2019
it's just about
I think just about sold a couple hundred
left I have to keep promoting it of
course and that is it alright go [ __ ]
yourselves
and I'll check in on you know oh wait
I'm sorry today is Thursday right have a
great weekend you [ __ ] that's what I'm
supposed to say and I'll talk to you on
Monday all right wait a second the
podcast isn't over yet I was supposed to
do an inch after the music there's gonna
be a little clip from one of the
uninformed episode three I believe from
the patreon page give you a little taste
they're like a drug deal it'll hopefully
make you go to the [ __ ] patreon and
listen to the rest of it so here it is
me and all Joe DeRosa the teen idol
sensation from the Opie and Anthony
program uh talking about uh I think
we're talking about being up me being a
dad on this one I'm not sure I don't
remember all right enjoy
[Music]
[Applause]
god bless the bureau some joke
god bless the people that love those
things you know people that [ __ ]
decorate their house on the holidays
Mia loves him he is a [ __ ] best
Nina's gonna [ __ ] you know check the
whole she's gonna deck the halls I'd say
right now John I almost throw out my
back pushing my [ __ ] trash cans to
the corner because they was fold with
like $300 worth of [ __ ] pumpkins that
she bought for [ __ ] Halloween and and
Thanksgiving and it looked great Joe I
like Martha Stewart would have walked in
she would have been nervous been like ah
[ __ ] this this chick is coming right
then at the end of the day they got a
[ __ ] you know they got to go out to
the curb
I was sitting liked it I I never get one
I'm like I'm just gonna have to throw it
away
Feli there was a [ __ ] dead body in
there dude it was they like wait as much
as a person I never get one cuz I'm
liking and I also never put my tree up
do you ever think if you did stuff like
that maybe you could sleep a little
better dude listen I love nothing more
than putting the tree up and decorating
for Christmas here's what I don't do
Bell what a bells bells that they're
like shaped the Harley bells or shaped
like only [ __ ] people they are trying
to get the quarters are these army
people well I don't know what branch
they're in
dang the dangly thing you knows guys at
the mall no that's no Holly bill the
[ __ ] green [ __ ] with the berries on
it Holly are you saying those Elle's
yeah they're called bells of Holly like
the things that you hang up those little
bunches of Holly oh I always said I just
thought was literally bells first I
thought was balls maybe it means bells
but I gotta be [ __ ] my way through
is what it is we gotta look up this
[ __ ] Joey has there ever been a
[ __ ] show named more perfectly
uninformed I took a wild swing but I
have a feeling a working title was dumb
[ __ ] that's got to be that's got to be
what it is though bells of Holly like
bit like like bales of hay or you know
what the [ __ ] does hey you have to do
with Holly I'm saying it's like the term
like how you call a thing a hay bale of
all right I think you just called a bell
of Harley you know a bushel of fruit in
other words everything somebody shape
bushels out there for me if you don't
know what it mean it bill you've been
shaving your bushel for years ah
we're both wrong deck the halls with
boughs of holly bo ugh s oboes follow la
la la la la la la tis the season to be
jolly fa la la la la la la la Don we now
our gay apparel falala Run DMC there
wait a second Don we are done we are
don't talk about joy dude
Don means put on our gay apparel meaning
joyous festive mean something out of
Bill's closet troll the ancient Yuletide
Carol I never got with that man through
this is like how much English language
changes this is like what the finally
what they're talking about you let's see
here you know somebody did like a metal
versions of this dude it's sick what the
[ __ ] is a bow a bow definition like a
bow like a boat it's not bo w it's a
main branch of a tree a branch a limb
and and dude that's where a bow and
arrow comes from I bet cuz you would
take a tree branch field W you sure
positive
well no I mean I'm just saying it is hot
so that's how I spell it
I'm bow and arrow yes definition of
above Jesus Joe we're just learning
stuff right and left bow definition a
man a male white male from the south
hey Bo you know sorry not tied with two
loops and two loose ends used
specifically to tie shoe that's not a
weapon for shooting arrows typically
made of a curved
piece of wood whose ends are joined
together by a taut string all right and
that's Bo w yep all right
I'm Joey D write down Joey D Lanie's
that's a scotch
all right that's uninformed Joe I like
that we sang a little holidays let's
let's walk let's let's end it this it's
it's the holiday season I don't know
that one it will be doobie Doo what is
that don't take out your [ __ ] at the
Christmas party to keep your neck nog in
your pants yes so don't walk up and grab
her tits unless she tells you to be safe
and don't do it ever walk those titties
get your [ __ ] hands and then take a
stroll in the snow and then what do you
know you're gonna [ __ ] her in the ass
it's the most wonderful time of the
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill Bert's the
Monday morning podcast for Monday
December 6 2010 how come I can't [ __ ]
hear myself what's going on here hello
hello
you [ __ ] what is going on hello
hello hello hello hello all the levels
seem right the [ __ ] am I doing wrong
lately I used to have this [ __ ] down
well I hope it's alright because it's
late in the day and I have a football
game to watch Patriots are playing the
Jets you know those two [ __ ] teams
I've been talking about for [ __ ] 19
weeks in a row they're playing tonight
so I got a [ __ ] hustle through this
thing cuz I'm doing this thing late cuz
I just flew back from San Francisco
I left my balls in San Francisco isn't
that how the song goes
Tony Bennett comes out luck be a lady to
night on that Frank Sinatra
go [ __ ] yourself there crooner fans what
do you think about that during the
holiday month as you can tell I I blew
out my voice when I was doing Cobbs
comedy club up in San Francisco and I
had a great [ __ ] time
51 days without drinking and I got to
tell you that's San Francisco is one of
those cities that makes you want to
drink I know it's just an awesome city
you go up there that's two weekends in a
row I've absolutely loved the city
Seattle last week and now San Francisco
this week in San Francisco it's what's
really I don't know how people stay
sober there cuz every time you walk
around the corner you just see one of
those bars you know it's just got that
warm old dingy but it's got some
character and you just want to [ __ ] go
in there and get a pint and just start
talking some [ __ ] you know it's [ __ ]
cold and rainy there the whole [ __ ]
weekend so psyched to be back in LA
those first time I seen the Sun and like
ten [ __ ] days it feels like I mean
with the potty-mouth
this week but anyways yeah I was up
there and I worked cops comedy club and
I want to thank all those people who
came out to see me it was a ridiculous
turnout
Cobb's is a two giant room for a comedy
club and the place was packed the entire
weekend and it was great everybody was
showing up bunch of people came up and
told me that they loved the podcast and
I had like five people come up to me and
tell me how much they liked the SoCo
what man they loved it so I'm thinking
actually turning that into a bit stick
it into my act I just don't know if it's
gonna work cuz I think maybe if I stick
my mouth close enough actually no and I
listen listen back to the podcast it
sounded like the it sounded like the
same sort of distortion I got to try it
out I really got to [ __ ] try it out
you know what there's a room out here
called the comedy Union I used to be
called mixed nuts it's called a comedy
Union it's down on La Brea and well it's
awful LaBrea can you remember so it's
right down the street from Roscoe's
Waffle House chicken and waffles
Roscoe's chicken and waffles huh
african-americans you listening to the
podcast there's a big shout-out to that
[ __ ] restaurant but anyways it's a
club you know any comedian can go down
there but it's a predominantly black
audience remember that from the news
they used to say that all the time a
predominantly black neighborhood
predominantly black neighborhood so
that's like what the crowds are so
whenever I have a joke like that I like
to go down to rooms like that or maybe
do Tuesday night at the Comedy Store
because I want to make sure that I'm
saying this [ __ ] the right way you know
granted that opens the door to some
awkwardness if it doesn't come off the
right way but that's the fun of doing
what I do so maybe I'm gonna head down
there speaking of Roscoe's chicken and
waffles I heard so much about that [ __ ]
so called what ma'am heard so much about
that [ __ ] from the predominantly black
comedians
always hyping that place up you got to
go down there you got to go down there
and I got to tell you something
I like chicken and I like waffles but I
do not like that [ __ ] together
all right at no point in my life did
syrup ever need to touch a chicken it's
uh it's [ __ ] gross and I went there
once and I'll never go there again
it was one of those uh you ever go to
like a soul food place and it's like
[ __ ] like hardcore African American
and you feel foolish as your ordering
because everything's named after like
some civil rights leader you know
welcome to Roscoe's chicken waffle can I
take your order yeah let me get the
Frederick Douglass chili fries
and can I get the medgar evers edamame
whatever the [ __ ] you just feel dumb
saying it so I don't know if it's that
bad where the [ __ ] was that Amy Ruth's
we're going back in my career here back
in my career when I used to I used to
[ __ ] jump over on both sides of the
fence all the goddamn time
back in the good old days that was that
was a period in my career where I made
sure that I on a regular basis when I
was trying to figure out how to say what
you know these glorious dick jokes and
[ __ ] jokes that I do on stage there was
a period during my career when I would
when I would I would do all the rooms I
could get in front of all the crowds and
if you're comedian I suggest that you do
that because it can do nothing but help
you and you know if you're really you
know what I mean
I learned that [ __ ] because I saw Eddie
Murphy on the Rotter way back in the day
I saw Rodney Dangerfield's Dangerfield's
there was two of them
Roger Dangerfield and then two weeks
later I saw Eddie Murphy on the rod tour
and I was like [ __ ] at 18 years old and
I remember looking at Eddie's crowd
versus Rodney's crowd and for some
[ __ ] reason that just clicked to me
like Rodney's hilarious but Eddie is
making everybody laugh so I remember
kind of knew I wanted to be a comedian
at that point but it took me another few
years to get the balls you know to go
onstage and then also had this [ __ ]
thing in my head that you know I had to
make sure I finished college
got to make sure I got tens of thousands
of dollars worth of debt worth of debt
so then I can then go on stage and talk
about my dick right to make my life even
more difficult um look I'm not saying
whether or not you should go to college
or you shouldn't but if you were like me
and you just [ __ ] knew you know you
looked at stand-up comedy and you just
you just [ __ ] knew I I don't think
would be the worst thing if he just said
to hell with the next you know $40,000
worth of debt but who the [ __ ] am I Who
am I to say that how far are we into the
top seven minutes in seven [ __ ]
minutes and I could tell you oh my god
I'm [ __ ] redlining on this [ __ ] here
seven minutes in I don't think I have
anything left to talk about I am so
[ __ ] frazzle cuz I don't know what
happens when I fly back on the day of a
podcast it's just I don't have any funny
there's no funny in me right now I'm
just sitting here like I might as well
be on Meet the Press you know talking
about budgets for the upcoming fiscal
year
did anything interesting happen to me in
San Francisco of course not I wasn't
drinking I'll tell you that I went out
and I tried a bunch of food up there and
I'll this is something I can guarantee
you all right if you like a burrito go
to San Francisco those guys I had a
burrito when I was up in San Francisco
I've been thinking about I'm always
[ __ ] thinking about it before I even
said what I just said I've been thinking
about this [ __ ] like you know you ever
just bang some [ __ ] just
you know some girl you're never gonna
marry but she I don't know what she does
I don't want to get graphic I try to
stay away from the sex ship but you know
and he just can't stop [ __ ] thinking
and your brains going don't go back to
her she's out of her [ __ ] mind
she said that's not a mother that's not
a mom you're not gonna marry her don't
[ __ ] go back but what she did on the
other side right come on we're all
adults you know what I'm talking you
can't stop [ __ ] thinking about it I
had the food version of that and
goddamnit
it was a burrito in San Francisco and
like a [ __ ] [ __ ] I can't even tell
you where I got it I guess I can go I
can go on the internet here and try and
find it by the way here's a YouTube
video for you I'm a huge Stevie Ray
Vaughan fan huge Stevie Ray Vaughan fan
and he did a cover of an Albert King
song called a I just say ain't gonna
give up on love but it's ain't gone and
give up on love I'm too white to say it
that way so I say ain't gonna give up on
love and the guy who put it up his SRV
music like Stevie Ray Vaughan music
video SRV music video put it up like a
year ago for some reason I missed it and
you got to see this if you're a fan of
guitar playing even if you don't like
blues guitar Stevie Ray Vaughan he gets
like 3/4 of the way through his second
blistering solo and he [ __ ] does this
little spin move undoes the [ __ ]
guitar straps and then I'll the guitars
behind him straps the [ __ ] guitar
back on and proceeds to finish the solo
behind his back and not only is he
playing with the guitar behind his back
he takes the solo to a whole nother
level beyond the Stevie Ray Vaughan
level he was just at its the [ __ ]
like if somebody can show me anybody who
can play behind their back with that
level of passion that [ __ ] good I
mean I don't know if Hendrix could do
that Hendrix used to [ __ ] I mean I
know Hendrix is a better [ __ ]
guitarist I'm not even gonna start that
[ __ ] argument all right that's like
comparin Jordan to Kobe
I get it I'm not even trying to say it
before we even have this [ __ ]
argument Jimmy is yeah you can't even
touch that guy but I'm just saying he
took that that you know that stage trick
to a whole nother [ __ ] let's just
watch it and actually if you can find me
one a Jimmy doing it better which I'm
sure you can maybe I haven't looked hard
enough I'd love to see it because I get
[ __ ] chills watching this [ __ ]
so anyways I'm gonna I'm gonna get rid
of this screen here I'm gonna find the
name of this [ __ ] burrito place
because it was it was [ __ ] amazing
now I can't look for this as I'm doing
this podcast isn't this gonna get boring
for you guys huh I'm typing with my
middle finger Cisco you're as funny
about people in San Francisco every time
I go there somewhere I either read or
somebody tells me that nobody calls the
city San Fran and I really want to tell
them that nobody I know calls it San
Fran we just say San Francisco we don't
call it Frisco either like you [ __ ]
hit people in San Francisco we don't
call it we just say safe San Francisco
go to San Francisco I wouldn't say I'm
going to shy instead of Chicago would I
I guess people say shy town all right
here we go I am [ __ ] zeroing in where
I got this goddamn burrito I'm gonna
find this I'm gonna want a satellite
like the [ __ ] Illuminati does you
know that when they're staring at you
watching you [ __ ] rubbing one out
saving the video so if you ever go
against all right it's on uh you
[ __ ]
give me the satellite come on give me
that [ __ ] don't you like how the
Illuminati has allowed us to do this too
so it won't seem as creepy when they
[ __ ] do it to us is that it all right
there you go I got it it's on you can't
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
there it is right there it's on 9th
Avenue and Irving Street all right
Yancy's saloon on that side of the road
you walk down you make a right on ninth
[ __ ] Avenue now I'm gonna take the
little yellow man the little asian dude
right is that it was supposed to be huh
put him down on the street look at me
and there's where the [ __ ] I was slowly
going down the street isn't this
exciting isn't this is what you get when
you get a free [ __ ] podcast you get
absolutely no look at a poodle that this
satellite took a picture of you think
it's still alive it's one of those
bigger poodles you know like the George
Mikan of poodles you know those big ones
they're actually really good at frisbee
they actually become a dog when they get
that big all right where the [ __ ] is it
you [ __ ] [ __ ] don't be like this I
don't [ __ ] know I told you basically
where it is and it's on the [ __ ] west
side of the street anyways I had a
goddamn burrito I'm still thinking about
it Here I am in the middle of the
podcast doing one of the most boring
things I could possibly do is which is
search for the thing that's how good
this [ __ ] burrito was I'm literally
stalking it just so I can look on stand
outside the window via my [ __ ] laptop
all right that was excruciating ly
boring and if this podcast wasn't free I
[ __ ] apologize for it uh-huh so hey I
got a letter here for some fan from
Alaska all right you ever hear that
expression where they say you can't run
from your problems well tell people in
Alaska because most people up there are
wanted you know and not in a good way
like we really love you to come back to
South Dakota they are wanted in one of
those you know you know those [ __ ]
idiots those spur-of-the-moment bank
robbers we stand in there and the only
reason why you robbed the bank was
because the line was just long enough to
give you enough time to think like you
know what I could always rob this
[ __ ] Bank
and if there was no one in front of you
you just would have gone in and found
out what you know what your balance was
but there was just you know seven people
in front of you you started working out
the whole thing you know the [ __ ]
going on look at everybody we all work
every single day and every week
they give us a check they don't give us
cash they give us a check they give us
these numbers on a piece of paper and
what do we do with it we take it right
down to these [ __ ] we give them all our
money you know
this is this I feel like a [ __ ]
hooker right now I went out and I worked
alright I get my money in this form of
[ __ ] currency that I can I can't even
use unless I go to you you [ __ ]
[ __ ] and then you keep the [ __ ] I
gotta stick it in there you give it out
to me twenty dollars at a time telling
me everything's gonna be okay
I want you know something I would love
to go to a bank where they actually had
the nerve to walk around in like purple
sparkly suits with big feathers you know
driving Lincoln Continentals from 1975
just dressed like the [ __ ] pimp that
you are I'll give a [ __ ] up doll myself
up to go in there and try and get my
money you [ __ ] [ __ ] so anyways this
is a this is a letter from crazy Alaskan
fan said a pill I bought let it go on
iTunes earlier this evening and had
quite the [ __ ] goat rope I don't know
what that means I'm sure that means like
I was freaking out in Alaska I had quite
the [ __ ] goat rope
the [ __ ] would that mean the Italia go
to your cabin up there go to eat
everything I don't get it
crazy Alaskan fan can you please explain
that to me I don't know you had quite
the [ __ ] goat rope okay that doesn't
sound like it was good
anyways I live out in the middle of be
Fe Alaska I don't know what that means
either
Sena in area is that bum [ __ ] East
Alaska I don't know and have no need for
the Internet in my Ted Kaczynski cabin
according to Marc Maron on Twitter Ted
Kaczynski's cabin is actually for sale
but I digress here we go continuing my
neighbor who is down the road has has
the Internet and if I sit my laptop
sideways facing due south on the very
top of my Warren Commission volumes I
can connect at tip top 1997 speed I only
do this once a month so I went on iTunes
and I bought let it go Joao de Rosa's
album the depression auction and some
Chuck Berry look at that you got great
taste too great comedians and one of the
greatest guitarists of all time um
alright Michael graves
I don't know what that if I'm saying
that right and the latest Iron Maiden
effort I picked all the tunes out that I
wanted sat my laptop on it's 7-foot
perch on its side so I could download
let it go so I let it download all that
[ __ ] alright i sat down and out of the
corner of my eye I saw Sarah McLaughlin
written on the screen and I immediately
thought oh [ __ ] I somehow hit the wrong
button and I [ __ ] bought some Sarah
McLaughlin song so I grabbed it for the
computer and there it went right down
the to the [ __ ] floor seven feet down
onto a linoleum floor boom I started
screaming at the top of my lungs about
that [ __ ] Sarah McLaughlin and those
prick bastards at iTunes for faking me
out and making me buy that dumb [ __ ] I
was really freaking out
I open my front door to cool off and
they
four feet in front of me was a big brown
bear looking at me like I was some kind
of [ __ ] I grabbed the door and ran
like hell back in liquor
lickety-split look at he split now
that's the kind of [ __ ] expression
you use if you live in a cab [ __ ]
goat rope look at he split my heart was
beating like crazy I was surprised to
see and I walked up to my computer and I
was surprised to see that my screen was
okay on the laptop it fired right up
away holy SH ed it works when I reloaded
iTunes I saw Sarah Sarah McLaughlin was
actually one of the comedy cuts on let
it go I let it go alright ya crazy
Alaskans phanpy Jesus Christ Pete that
sounds like some [ __ ] I would do do you
guys do that a lot do you absolutely
lose your [ __ ] you know you build up
some sort of conspiracy in your [ __ ]
head and then you realize in the end
that you were actually wrong you know
but in that moment you by yourself and
you try to blow it off by turning the
car radio on and try to drown out that
voice that screaming voice in your head
and that feeling of embarrassment that
you you were actually the douchebag and
then he just wasted the last whatever
5-7 minutes of your life absolutely
flipping out about some [ __ ] that you
know really didn't didn't even [ __ ]
happen or maybe some [ __ ] that you
created if you did then you can relate
to the first thirty seven years of my
life people cuz that's what the [ __ ] I
did look at my goddamn fingernails I
need to cut my fingernails I've been on
the road too goddamn long hey guys is it
okay if I just tap out can I just you
know you know I feel like right now when
you guys are at work and you just don't
want to be there so then you just you
start faking sick you know you get that
douchey look on your face you know you
just you know you just start speaking in
a whiny softly yeah you don't really
excuse me boss excuse me yeah I don't I
don't know if it's something I ate I
started feeling like this the other day
you always have to give it credibility
I started feeling this way the other day
really you were pretty [ __ ] chipper
when he came walking in you know
let me tell you guys about that cokehead
I used to work with a long time ago used
to come walking into the warehouse like
four hours late on a sunny day with his
hair soaking wet from a shower and his
excuse was always the same uh the
traffic traffic was unbelievable really
it's [ __ ] 92 degrees out there buddy
with your soak and wet hair I don't even
know who was from a shower could have
been like that drugged sweat what time I
was doing the Opie and Anthony show and
they had some guys some [ __ ] rock
band guys in there that were the [ __ ]
I'm not gonna [ __ ] blow up the spot
and say their name because it was like
8:30 in the morning when they came in we
interviewed him for like an hour and at
9:30 in the morning I asked the lead
singer if I can get a picture with him
and he goes sure he [ __ ] pulled me
into him and that his head [ __ ] side
of his face up against my side of the
face and it was just I don't know what
it was flop sweat drug sweat and meth
sweat I don't know what the [ __ ] it was
but you have if you ever [ __ ] play
basketball and you play shirts and skins
and the fatty not only you got to cover
the fatty but he [ __ ] his skins and
they're in that transition games and you
[ __ ] you're standing there in the
paint and that fatty goes running by and
you feel like ah like somebody just
empty the jacuzzi on you that's what it
felt like was [ __ ] disgusting
oh wait a minute there it is there's the
burrito spot
it's called Gordo Geor do there we go
there we go
on 9th Avenue in Irving
North on 9th Avenue Irving Street was
the [ __ ] [ __ ] it's one of those things
if I was like Elvis Presley you know hey
man let's go get a [ __ ] burrito man
I'm all hopped up on quaaludes and [ __ ]
I want to [ __ ] burrito man I would get
him a private jet Van Nuys and I'd fly
like nine of my friends up who don't
really like me at that point they're
just there for the money and they're
laughing at all my jokes like I'm the
funniest [ __ ] ever you know hey man
where'd you get those shoes at a shoe
store and they're all like oh man
everything I say it's funny everything
everything I sing is a [ __ ] hit let's
go get a [ __ ] burrito
that stewardess thinks you'll suck my
dick everybody laughing like sex or
sexual harassment didn't exist back then
if you sold enough [ __ ] records in the
70s sexual harassment
didn't exist in the 60s yeah you could
just you could just rape somebody if you
had a hit record
if anybody complained I pipe down how
many albums did you sell there
sweetheart it's a brutal [ __ ] time to
be a female you know so we had to
correct it and the only way we knew we
would have known we never would have
found out if those ladies didn't start
burning their bras how many of those
[ __ ] ex-hippies do you think that
regret that moment standing in the
street what what exactly was their
[ __ ] problem with a brassiere you
know what do you want you want
Teddy's hanging down to your waist you
don't want that the number one [ __ ]
thing that gets you some [ __ ] little
things during the course of the day oh
man would you like to go first go ahead
do you think I'm being a gentleman I'm
not being a gentleman it's cuz you have
perky titties all right and you had the
[ __ ] decency to only button your
shirt right up to just below your
cleavage you because of that yes madam
you can go before me if I had a hat I
would take it off and I would bend over
at the waist like like like one of those
three musketeers you know throw my
[ __ ] coat down over a puddle water
you know there you are man
right that's cuz he get titties what
keeps your titties perky ladies what
keeps him yeah aside from eating steamed
vegetables instead of a quart upon it
with cheese come on we all know your
goddamn brassiere all right
see see [ __ ] the sports bra whatever
the [ __ ] you want if you want to keep
those babies high and tight alright I
know it's hard for you to hear this from
a man it's coming off showed
chauvinistic alright
if I was you know some [ __ ]
motivational speaker and I was a female
standing up here saying the exact same
[ __ ] but I had a clam you'd be listening
you'd be listening you buy my stupid
books and I'd have those [ __ ] I'm
smart glasses on you know you know those
women dress they walk that fine line of
having a business suit on but they still
look like you know I'll [ __ ] the [ __ ]
out of you you know that look exactly
speaking of that you guys seen that
[ __ ] I'm walking around right now I
gotta stand up let the funny fall down
wash over me you guys watch that show uh
I don't know what the hell it's called
but you know what I mean that's its it
stars this woman it's kind of like that
show you know let's show her that bald
guys screaming about the stalks and he's
throwing stuffed animals around and for
some stupid [ __ ] reason people look I
know why people listen cuz he's loud
he's passionate I've made a [ __ ]
career out of that if you just say my
jokes without screaming them and working
up a sweat I don't think they're that
funny you know the true masters the bill
Bill Cosby can sit in a lawn chair and
kill for two straight hours I couldn't
do that Jesus Christ if I sat down for
two hours to try to tell jokes just the
sound of my own voice would that put me
asleep forget about the [ __ ] crowd
but anyways so I'm watching the show
late night cuz I'm not drinking you know
staying in this [ __ ] hotel down on
Jefferson Street and hide the Apocalypto
whatever the [ __ ] it's called you know
what's funny I think I took a picture -
I'm gonna put it on the MM podcast.com
for some [ __ ] reason do you guys ever
see that movie Shaka Zulu is that the
name of it chuckles ooh whoo Shaka Zulu
Zulu for Hulu whatever the [ __ ] it's
called right it's basically about uh
yeah I know what the [ __ ] was if I was
about English guys in Africa and they
went down there and they took over some
[ __ ] and the Zulu Nation had had enough
right
and they they all stood on the [ __ ]
hill and that their deaths slamming
their [ __ ] weapons against their uh
their shields that's the [ __ ] you know
Michael Caine and all those guys
remember they were dressed
those stupid white hats
I don't know what I don't know what it
looked like you know what it looked like
do you mean you guys ever watched
bonanza remember that guy Hoss or that
10-gallon [ __ ] hat just imagine if
you had that hat but you cut the brim
off of it he just left that big stupid
hat on man maybe got a little bit of a
brim on the front and on the back like
if uh what do you call those those
little hats you know those little hats
that [ __ ] people wear like Charlie
Chaplin just imagine if that hat could
get an erection right and the [ __ ]
brim was the balls so you know they just
[ __ ] staying the same that's what the
Hat looked like okay for some fucked-up
reason the the I wasn't say the guards
the dudes who stand outside on the
sidewalk and go hey can I help you with
that bag that you obviously carried here
with no problem so I can possibly make a
couple of dollars those guys the doorman
there you go they were dressed like
those [ __ ] Englishman and Shaka Zulu
or chukkas oolo Zulu Hulu whatever the
[ __ ] it's called I don't know why I
thought to need to bring that up well
let's talk about the hotel they had a
wine tasting place right next door you
know which just attracts soccer moms
it's [ __ ] ridiculous
you know those goddamn broads when they
get older they have a couple of kids
they can't go out and do keg stands with
their hoo-hah hanging out of their
panties anymore they're a [ __ ] mom so
they got to be you know they got to be
more mature with their drinking so they
go out to places like those little those
wine bars music isn't too loud you know
doesn't make their tits quiver right so
they can sit down sit down with their
friends they have cheese they got wine
and they could sit there and discuss
[ __ ] you know and act like they're
[ __ ] adults rather than just scared
teenagers with children the [ __ ] so I
had a walk by that [ __ ] all the time and
evidently one of these broads had too
much to drink I don't know what somebody
[ __ ] yakked on my floor it was
cleaned up before I got there but you
know that you know once somebody pukes
that's just gonna be there it's gonna be
there for a week you need a new rug
who's kidding who all right
if you puke enough they really need to
tear down the building so anyways I mean
I got in that [ __ ] subject but this
is good man I got a little bit of
momentum I stood up feeling alright
alright oh I know what I was talking
about I was talking about that lady I
was watching on the show so uh I'm not
drinking so I'm back in the hotel where
the dudes are dressed like the [ __ ]
apartheid Englishmen at the door and
somebody yakked on my floor I'm sitting
there watching this [ __ ] show that's
how I got there all right
so watching the show and flipping
through the channels and watching TV and
I'm flipping through the [ __ ]
channels I'm losing all my goddamn bet
someone one-in-three this week I'm
flipping through the [ __ ] channels
and I stop on this show and it's this
lady I don't know what her deal is
but like adults call her up and say I
want to buy this can I afford it
you know
[ __ ] eight years old
just call hey shoes and this is this is
Jill I'm calling from Arkansas
first of all I'll tell you I love your
show I absolutely love it
me and my husband we watch it all the
time we absolutely love it we think
you're great and you know a lot of
people probably think that you put too
much bleach on your teeth especially
with that orange fake tan you know so
you look like that [ __ ] plant in
Little Shop of Horrors but that's not me
I think you look great all right they go
through all that [ __ ]
so this [ __ ] calls up and they're why
do I say that and I never talk to women
that way so this lady says I want to
[ __ ] I want I want to buy I want to
buy a [ __ ] condo down in Florida do I
have enough money y'all haven't can I
afford it that's what the [ __ ] she said
called up this complete [ __ ] stranger
says I want to buy a condo and ask this
other [ __ ] complete [ __ ] stranger
can I afford it
it's like
did you mail this woman all your bank
records like five [ __ ] years ago and
you have him do you have no [ __ ] idea
how much money you have you dumb [ __ ]
Jesus and everything what the whole
[ __ ] hour was hey my name's Mike I'm
calling in from Rhode Island listen I
want to get a tattoo on my [ __ ] ball
bag but I also want to cut out the roof
so I can get T tops on my [ __ ] 85
rally sport can I afford to do that
that's what the show was this woman
telling adults
who had jobs and lives and probably
children whether or not they could
afford something it just really was [ __ ]
you know that was one of those times was
just like you know what there's not
enough lightning in the world you know
just as far as the odds of being struck
by lightning we need to bring that
average up because the amount of [ __ ]
morons out there versus actually
intelligent people you're gonna hit a
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know basically gonna
hit a [ __ ] are you gonna hit the ocean
those are gonna be the top two in that
order even though the [ __ ] world is
three-quarters [ __ ] water you still
got a higher chance as lightning to
[ __ ] hit a [ __ ] that's that that's
I'm telling you that's my goddamn theory
and that's what I want the Neustadt to
be rather than being like you know the
the odds of getting hit by lightning are
higher than bla bla bla I wanted to turn
into I want so much lightning that that
that the Neustadt is the odds of an
intelligent person actually being hit by
lightning our x y&z do you like how in
my own little Stalin s world that I'm
actually intelligent and everybody else
is just a sea of morons huh you don't
have thoughts like that murderous
thoughts I was actually talking to this
broad up in San Francisco and
I got this whole chunk about hitting
women that I've been doing on stage and
it's actually something embarrassing I
have to admit about myself as much as I
do the comedy thing for a living I'm
really bad at picking up on sarcasm I
don't know why I use sarcasm I'm
sarcastic right but for some reason when
someone uses it against me I I just like
thing like that old guy downstairs mom I
told you that [ __ ] last year when I was
dragging my Christmas tree down the
stairs he stuck his head out the window
and he just goes beautiful morning isn't
it and he had this [ __ ] up look on his
face but he said beautiful morning isn't
it so I was confused and I just went
yeah yeah is a beautiful morning I'm
thinking why is he yelling with that
twisted up look on his face and then I
walked around the corners like wow he
didn't mean it
he what he really meant was she making a
lot of [ __ ] noise ruining this
beautiful morning so he got me that I
always end up feeling stupid so you know
I'm doing this whole chunk on hitting
the broads over there right and I'm
standing afterwards whoring myself out
right selling my DVD showing a little
bit of leg doing what I got to do and
this [ __ ] woman is walking out and
her husband is sort of shuffling her out
and she starts going oh yes she is his
once again that twisted up look on her
face
she goes thanks for the domestic
violence jokes I really appreciated it I
really appreciated the domestic violence
jokes thanks a lot for the domestic
violence jokes that's what she was doing
and because she was saying thanks it
just it went totally past my head I was
more just confused by her facial
expression so she said oh yeah I really
appreciated it thanks a lot I'm
literally just waving gone
alright glad you enjoyed the show which
is funny because it probably pissed her
off more but I was sincerely thanking
her completely missing her sarcasm what
she was really saying was I've either
dealt with that personally or that's
happening to somebody right now or has
happened to someone or I grew up with it
or whatever and you brought up bad
memories and you ruined my [ __ ]
evening that's what she was really
saying but of course I took it at face
value which is actually when I look back
on it I think makes it even funnier
because who's kidding who she already
thinks I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] at that point
you know so there would actually
what a made her a little bit happier if
I try to appear intelligent it's like
actually you missed the point of that
joke oh I was really trying to do is
expose the hypocrisy of some of the
relationships between the male and
female sections if I went that route you
know then she could have gotten this one
but the fact that I literally was The
[ __ ] that she thought I was and then
that there was this whole line of people
you know what I just realized I should
be struck by lightning what the [ __ ] is
wrong with me I'm one of those [ __ ]
morons um all right so there's that
portion of the [ __ ] program that's 36
minutes dude I'm not there's no way I'm
going more than 50 minutes I got to make
a judgment call here like I'm trying to
find some friends where I can watch this
Patriots Jets game cuz I I can't go out
and watch just regular games at a sports
bar unless it's a team I don't give a
[ __ ] about but there's no way a game
like this that I care so much about I
don't do a lot of people this is gonna
be a huge [ __ ] game which obviously
it is but I gotta be honest with you I
I'm not feeling our defense I really
want to talk some [ __ ] but I gotta be
honest with you okay you guys want to
hear my big prediction I'm gonna go out
on a limb here rather than all these
other [ __ ] [ __ ] who email me
after the game and don't make any sort
of prediction this is my prediction I
think
obviously you guys know I don't like our
[ __ ] defense but I got a bin I got to
tell you this we have no [ __ ] pass
rush and the Jets have a [ __ ]
incredible offensive line those guys are
the [ __ ]
so what's-his-face Sanchez is gonna be
sitting back there like Bill Cosby doing
a stand-up special and then you combine
the fact that we have a [ __ ] defense
that lets up 24 to 30 [ __ ] points a
game I don't like that aspect of it but
I believe in our offense I think our
offense is great but they have a great
defense so I don't know I just really
see this being one of those 28 to 17 you
know don't listen to my gambling tips
but if I was gambling and I actually had
to put money on this it was my last
[ __ ] hundred bucks I would I would
take the jets in the [ __ ] points but
uh but if the Patriots do win because we
got [ __ ] Tom Brady and we have the
genius of Bill Belichick who can somehow
figure out a way during the second half
to come back I think even if they win I
still don't think it means [ __ ] other
than that we've come a long way since
September but we'd still have to I think
right we'd still have to play the G I
don't know then if the playoffs came
around I'd a playoffs
I don't know I don't know this game is
gonna be [ __ ] awesome plus you also
to look at but uh Rex Ryan has buddy
Ryan at his fingertips so this is Dell
this is gonna be a [ __ ] awesome game
this is really gonna be an awesome game
and I'm gonna age at least eight [ __ ]
years I'm not gonna be able to handle it
like I got to tell you some games like I
keep this out [ __ ] psycho I get like
I give a [ __ ] so much sometimes I tape
the game and I don't even watch it and
then I just find out if my team wins
then I'll sit down and watch it but if
they lose I just [ __ ] erase the game
because that that's how much it affects
me you know and I know you thought out
what are you a [ __ ] [ __ ] yes
I don't know if I [ __ ] up from [ __ ]
intelligent it's like I don't want I
want to waste
dad I'm out of my [ __ ] life I I don't
want to care that much and I but I do so
I try to protect myself oh so let me
tell you guys about Sanford so if you go
into San Francisco if you're going to
San Francisco here's some [ __ ] to know
there public transportation system takes
it takes a minute to kind of get to
figure it out they have like all these
different subway lines that they're like
streetcars and then they go underground
they all sort of funnel inter down there
the Union Square area the Union Square
area as far as I can tell is the most
touristy [ __ ] place like the Times
Square of San Francisco in that I don't
think anybody from San Francisco goes
there
I think people from Oakland go in and
douchebags like me go down there before
they figure out like oh this place sucks
but I actually if the lines not too long
you can jump on one of those rice-a-roni
trolleys and you can go all the way up
to [ __ ] North Beach hang on who do we
got here ah Jesus these are the guys
calling about the game okay Ben I'm
doing my podcast let me call you back in
like 20 minutes all right
not cool um all right yeah so I don't
know if you go there with your girl
there's all the shops are down there so
you're gonna want to go they already
told you where to get a burrito actually
if you just want to go to burrito ground
central go to go to the Mission District
and this is just for people if you're
going to San Francisco and then there's
just all kinds of [ __ ] awesome bars
and I actually was staying uh you know
what it [ __ ] rain the entire time I
was there
what else did I go I got some decent
Italian food I went to that place Mama's
for breakfast I wasn't really impressed
but I got french toast and I figured
most people don't you know something
that's something that a lot of people
don't know how to make I can actually
make better french toast than most the
[ __ ] [ __ ] out there you know they
just don't do it right
they just don't [ __ ] do it right the
bread just doesn't taste right I go old
fashioned way my mom used to make it you
know you actually use white bread that
Wonder Bread [ __ ] and I know it's a
lower quality meat [ __ ] bread than
they use but I'm telling you sometimes
you can overthink something you get too
[ __ ] fancy look I'll tell you right
now you go out and make yourself a fried
egg you fry it up in butter
alright [ __ ] the Surgeon General every
once in a while you gotta tell that guy
to stand the [ __ ] down alright sit it
out oh man I'm cooking this [ __ ] and
butter right but your stupid [ __ ]
half a beard Surgeon General looks like
he already [ __ ] died did he die when
he had that like like he was the
commander-in-chief of all the love boats
that [ __ ] uniform so whatever you fry
it up and butter
alright you cook it over easy take it
easy
alright cook it over easy I don't know
how to [ __ ] you guys do it when I do
something over easy I [ __ ] I turn the
egg once alright after I cook the
[ __ ] egg and I get it to the
consistency I want what I cook it on low
heat too by the way
Russia cooked Christ you cook they [ __ ]
out of it you cook it on a low heat
right and then what you do is once you
get it looking the way you want it to
look y'all so you put your salt and
pepper on the top right as it's [ __ ]
cooking in the butter then you flip it
over and the second you flip it over you
take it off the heat all right and you
let how hot the the pan already is
cooked the other side all right it's
almost like marking a steak that's how
you do the other side that way you get
you know the egg isn't runny you know
but you still got the yolk there all
right oh that's how I make an egg over
easy but if I'm making a [ __ ] fried
egg you know you got to cook the thing
over hard same [ __ ] you cook it in
butter sit the [ __ ] down old man he
kicked you cook it an old butter he'd do
that all that [ __ ]
and he just you want Wonder Bread you
want the shittiest [ __ ] bread ever
all right the kind of [ __ ] that you're
not gonna digest to you like sixty two
slices of Wonder Bread
all right you salt and pepper that [ __ ]
she cook it in [ __ ] butter you put it
on the goddamn sandwich and then you put
a little mustard on top of it nothing
[ __ ] fancy not that grape upon [ __ ]
I'm talking broke-ass white-trash
[ __ ] my mustard all right
yellow plastic container comes out
yellow like mustard should be not that
golden [ __ ]
none of that stuff straight up all right
you [ __ ] you know put that [ __ ] on a
plate you go to town it's delicious
straight-up [ __ ] comfort food all
those [ __ ] places I don't know why
they don't just make [ __ ] like that just
you know it's like the McDonald's
concept but you actually use sort of
real food oh speaking of that you know
when I was walking through Haight
Ashbury or the Haight you don't wanna
get a [ __ ] look like oh you're a
tourist just say I want to go to the
hate I don't we get to the hate right
you go to [ __ ] and that I know what
the [ __ ] I still feel stupid saying that
but you go out there you know and that's
where all the dirty white people are hey
man can you spare some [ __ ] change me
in they got dreadlocks and [ __ ] you know
their dirty [ __ ] Wrangler jeans from
sitting on the [ __ ] sidewalk I really
AM reverse racist when it comes to
[ __ ] white homeless people you know
okay if you're white and you're [ __ ]
homeless and you're under the age of
sixty-two you're not getting a [ __ ]
dime out of me
you're just not unless you maybe if
you're a female then you got that look
you know you got that right look I'll do
it you know but other than that say come
on man seriously get a [ __ ] job
you're a [ __ ] white dude go get a
[ __ ] job I really should be making
those jokes in this economy I apologize
but you know what I'm saying
all right I'm talking about I'm not
talking about you if you're out of work
right now and you're looking for a job
hang in there and [ __ ] respect you
right but I'm talking about those other
bumps talking about bums in their 20s
all right this is a deal if you're white
if you look like boxcar Willie you know
you got to stick with that little
kerchief tad to it I'll give you some
money you know if you can stick your
nose in your mouth because you don't
have any [ __ ] teeth I'll give you
some money you know but as far as the
rest of the people go you get money out
of me if you look like you're sober
other than that you can go [ __ ] yourself
whatever happen what does [ __ ] like this
in December this is what old st. Nick is
coming down the [ __ ] tube right oh
you better watch out you better not cry
you better not pout I'm telling you why
Santa Claus is coming to town you know
what did I tell you guys I went up to
went to this observatory and I was
looking at stars the other night cuz I'm
not [ __ ] drinking and I'm desperately
trying to fill these hours when I used
to have fun in my life
and I was looking at the moons of
Jupiter and one of the moons was named
after some [ __ ] see if I had the
information here was named after
to [ __ ] with think like you know what I
can win this you guys don't need to know
the name you don't give a [ __ ] one of
the moons of Jupiter is named after
Jupiter was basically the Roman Zeus
right when it comes to mythology if I
remember correctly they basically stole
all their gods like stealing like a
[ __ ] script idea and I just changed
up the names of the characters like nah
man it's different we talking about so
Jupiter was married to I don't know I
don't know what the [ __ ] name was
Apollonia right I'm just gonna use fake
names here and they had a daughter named
Heather or Helena I don't know what the
[ __ ] her name was one of the moons is
named after this girl now evidently this
is how this this is how the story goes
in mythology is
Jupiter had basically a crush on his own
[ __ ] daughter and his wife rather
than reporting it to the proper
authorities was just simply jealous like
he was banging some hottie down the
street rather than her [ __ ] daughter
so Jupiter's banging his own daughter
his wife gets wind of it
he gets [ __ ] nervous so he turns her
into a cow not his wife he turns his
beautiful daughter that he was banging
into a heifer
Heffer evidently is a [ __ ] [ __ ]
cow that hasn't given a calf yet you
know it's ready to be [ __ ] banged raw
dog style right
that's a [ __ ] story I swear to God
and for all you Jesus freaks out there
who are looking down your nose at that
sort of myth dog mythology your [ __ ]
religion starts the same goddamn way
Adam and Eve first two [ __ ] people
they were hanging out somehow they
became more people it's really weird
like that guy was basically this guy
told this [ __ ] story
or at least brought it up I guess he
didn't tell the whole story then I
researched it it's just the the incest
you wish the acceptance of incest back
in the day I don't know if it's creepy
or if it just makes sense
you know you gotta be you gotta be
asking yourself this all right
there's only 40 people on the planet
alright let's just say 25 of them Oh
women
fifteen of our men
that doesn't even add up does it there's
40 cat does 25 and 15 is 40 see that we
all learned something here today on the
podcast all right let's see let's say 15
of men and 25 of [ __ ] women all right
now who's kidding who you been to a bar
there's 25 [ __ ] women in there all
right how many of them could you
completely give a [ __ ] about twelve good
half of them you don't give a [ __ ]
you're stone sober
yeah whatever with your [ __ ] genes
beat it all right you got weird eyebrows
get the [ __ ] away from me I don't care
so 12 of them are out the window now you
get down to 13 women
how many of them are gonna be hot let's
use the bar analogy there's gonna be
about four hot once all right now if
there's 25 women and 15 guys and only
for those women are [ __ ] hot there's
a good goddamn chance that one of those
women is gonna be your daughter no laws
have been made about it you know there's
no real sortie we know they haven't even
invented the [ __ ] wheel yet or the
hammer there's no there's no
jurisdiction there's no jurisdiction
there's no laws I guess that that's why
it made sense like why all these
religions started that way and then Thor
banged his sister are in front of his
daughter and no nobody questioned the
[ __ ] so anyways I don't know what the
[ __ ] I'm talking about here people I'm
just trying to get to 50 and it's 51
minutes 45 seconds bump up butter up
it's time to go watch Monday Night
Football everybody all right
let's hope we have a nice fair game got
a lot of balls saying that as a Patriots
fan anyways I'm looking forward to this
I don't like it I don't have a good
[ __ ] feeling I just I don't like it
but what's great is is I had a feeling
that I was gonna go undefeated this week
for know with my picks and I went one in
three so the odds have it that the fact
that I think the Jets are gonna win
means my Patriots might win right does
that make any [ __ ] sense
alright listen to this [ __ ] faces I'm
gonna upload this thing and I'm gonna
put up some pictures that I took when I
was in San Francisco how hilarious is
that you know it's like all of a sudden
I'm not drinking on the road and now now
I'm taking pictures like a goddamn
tourist and I'm telling you how to fry a
[ __ ] egg I don't know if I like it
but I'm 51 days in I'm definitely gonna
drink again
I just need to learn to do it in
moderation so my head doesn't get all
big and fat all right well that's the
podcast for this week you guys all have
a wonderful week I hope all your dreams
come true and go [ __ ] yourself
[Music]